with previously on TV sense and that's
when the exorcist boys pops out
stick up our ass
[Music]
reading hey Dean daddy Nikken who taps
like this on a light when they flicker
we can accidentally burn your hand
trying to screw it in tighter first if
there was a company that could create
light bonds with a supernatural
resistance setting they would make a
mint
there was no way these blood drops came
from the body that he is looking at here
the geography just doesn't work unless
of course she's one of those rare
anti-gravity bleeders that I've been
hearing about so much lately
what does Denny Duquette think he's
gonna do here other than get himself
killed
I get the need to save your white fudge
she was not only on fire but pretty hard
to get to so she was on the goddamn
ceiling why is this firefighter still
sitting in the truck this long when all
the others are already out doing their
job you really wanted that super artsy
door handle opening from the outside
shot didn't you as the camera michael
bay's this Jessica introduction can I
ask a serious question is there a more
generic Halloween stereotype than the
[ __ ] nurse costume even in 2005 it's
clear that the super in Supernatural
does not stand for super progressive
supposed to be like 15 minutes ago we're
running late but it won't matter to
anything in the plot or ever be
mentioned again cliche and where's your
costume I guess she's not aware that
he's just ahead of the times considering
these Sam Winchester jean jacket
surprise becomes a very common costume
with sci-fi and horror conventions just
a few years after this hey it's gonna go
great better padalecki Bucky Bucky
better lucky because we're not exactly
the Bradys well it turns out the
Huxtables weren't exactly the Huxtables
so you should be good what I do is that
you not watch Friday Night Lights or
agents of shield I'm guessing after 13
seasons of this show and Counting I'm
almost positive that the CW network
guidelines are a all characters must be
insanely hot and B they must wear as
little clothing as they can get away
with Nick gee Dave really sure I know it
was dark in the room but you aren't
going to notice the person you were
fighting with for a full minute is
actually your brother also why would
Dean not immediately say this he's lucky
Sam didn't grab a knife or a baseball
bat with barbed wire on it that his dad
left him loving for something I know no
no I wouldn't dream of it well that
wines aged about as well as an apple
core know whatever you want to say you
can say it in front of her dad's on a
hunting trip based on their family
history what did Sam think Dean meant in
the first place this really shouldn't be
a surprise but still the women grew up
after mom was killed and dad's obsession
to find the thing that killed her but we
still haven't found the damn thing show
sherry shoving a lot of story into this
little brother least
family feud's position I slowed the
message down and ran it through a gold
wave they've got the hiss and this is
what I got first of all no second of all
ran it through a gold wave
I mean sure gold wave makes audio
software but wouldn't you just say you
ran it through gold wave what does a
gold weigh I never Croft photos by
running them through a photoshop I got
emails by running them through a hotmail
it's almost like he's just repeating
words he's on a script probably got Jim
Jack and Jose along with him and
probably a severe case of alcohol
poisoning if he's so drunk he's mixing
tequila and whiskey okay like you really
shouldn't feel on out here Troy clearly
has never seen person of interest yeah
who cares that I literally found you at
the side of the road in a tattered dress
and you're talking like you took all the
drugs even ghosts can rely on the power
of boners to get things done the real
question is don't you want yourself to
leave scary lady took you to scary place
and then scary disappear why are you
even still here Troy is learning the
hard way that a supernatural [ __ ]
does not come with a happy ending how'd
you pay for that stuff
you and Dad still running credit-card
scams Jesus Sam maybe say that louder I
don't think the people in the next town
heard you house rules Sammy driver
fixing music shotgun shuts his cake hole
wouldn't that technically be car rules
sorry I can't hear you the music's too
loud and that same music will keep
playing with no cuts all the way through
when we hear Sam say thank you alright
so there's no one matching dad at the
hospital or morgue and then turn off
when you stop the car so are we supposed
to believe that in those 30 seconds of
continuous music you left the gas
station had a full conversation with the
hospital and stopped what less than half
a mile down the road who are you
federal marshals can anyone confirm that
this quick flash of a badge psychic
paper nonsense works in the real world I
mean even if they believed the badge
blur isn't there some kind of
confirmation that would need to happen
from above before a strange new federal
marshal got to play 20 questions
no sir we were just leaving agent Mulder
which is Scully show thinks that
name-dropping characters from the show
it obviously wants to be will keep me
from sinning it for raping the greatest
paranormal show of all time
well here's five sins for the
copycatting and another 15 for trying to
cover for it with the lame shot up it's
kind of a spoke a legend this one girl
she got murdered out on centennial good
thing the Winchester boys run into
people that give them the local urban
legend talk instead of more logical
paths that most people would take I
think he's been here for a couple days
at least because I'm an expert at the
ducing timeframes from the smell of
food I check [ __ ]
if this show did anything right from the
get-go it was the casting of the two
leads Jensen and Jared have great
chemistry and feel like real-life
brothers some of the other aspects of
the show might consist of CW nonsense
but these two riffing off each other
always gives the show the appearance
that it's a lot better than it probably
is
maybe I'm acing mistakes like kidnapping
Dana Scully and the show is going out of
it's Duane Barry way to make you think
of x-files I don't know how many times I
got to tell you it's my high school
locker combo even a cop in a small town
wouldn't know a locker combination would
have another dash in it you have to go
to the bathroom no forget the paperclip
if you were leaving a suspect locked up
in a room while you left how would you
not first remove every single thing from
their reach also they don't have one
other person around this station that
could perhaps Jensen sit just for a few
minutes
Spidy Spidy that's what a spider teen
does so is this ghost insinuating that
forced kissing counts as unfaithfulness
come to think of it that guy earlier
never actually did anything at all other
than agree verbally this is some sort of
Precog nonsense is there a paranormal
judicial system that makes rulings on
these cases so that the ghosts know who
they are and aren't allowed to kill I
know it was 2005 and all but these
effects just look shall we say super
unnatural or you think it's shooting
Casper the face you freak we'll handle
the relevant pop culture name-calling
around here Sammy greatest junior great
twist but what other chance is this what
happened as soon as he got home how did
the demon even know Sam would be coming
home at this time and why is the shower
running I'm sure all these questions
will be answered in the following
episode and we won't have to wait till
the end of the season to find out what
all this has to do with anything because
that would be at least 20 sins worth a
bullet
I'm making a rule never to get involved
we possess people at least tell me where
you're going do you think I'm pretty
doctor doctor maybe it's not murder I'm
not like you this is not going to be my
life
but I don't want your life hey are you
all right
I can't feel my leg you want to give us
your real name Jean Cocteau stone